vortex portail voyage temporel de tout
temps les hommes ont été fascinés par ce
saut vers l'inconnu et ont tenté à
travers de nombreuses oeuvres de fiction
de reproduire ce qui lui semblait
impossible mais voyager dans le temps
est il réellement impossible
les propos de cette jeune femme filmée
par nos caméras pourrait nous ouvrir une
voie où tout serait possible
ça a commencé dans mon précédent
logement j'étais dans ma chambre et tout
à coup j'ai senti une présence
vous voulez dire une présence
fantomatique un an bien elle est bien
vivante
elle portait une robe ancienne elle m'a
dit qu'elle s'appelait aliénor et
qu'elle venait du 15e siècle et qui est
devenu cette présence par la suite j'ai
dû l'héberger chez moi pouvait pas la
laisser sortir comme ça mais il y en a
eu d'autres
une vikings révolutionnaire pirates
ça fait des mois que je vois des
personnes d'autres époques défiler chez
moi sans aucune explication
viking pirates pictes cette jeune
historienne a vu défiler dans son salon
des dizaines de preuve de l'existence de
phénomènes surnaturels
elle qui se contentait de les étudier
dans des livres d'histoire jusque là et
vous pensez que votre appartement
pourrait se situer sur un portail où un
ancien cimetière indien cimetière indien
en france non d'autant que le phénomène
a continué quand j'ai déménagé dans mon
logement suivant une romaine
lucrecia a débarqué décolle pas de mon
canapé depuis les autres sont partis
vivre leur vie au 21ème siècle mais ali
nord et lucrecia squatte toujours chez
moi je ne sais pas quoi faire
sommes nous vraiment entouré de
voyageurs venus d'époque reculer comment
sont ils arrivés parmi nous et quelles
sont leurs intentions à notre égard
un dossier qui renferme encore bien des
mystères et que nous ne sommes
probablement pas prêt de refermer
et vous croyez vous au voyage temporel
avez-vous déjà croisé un voyageur venu
des temps reculés venait témoigner en
commentaires
et sur twitter grâce au hashtag time
warp
[Musique]
oh